[Music]
it was a weird scene in Washington today
President Trump you'll remember ran for
office promising to fix immigration make
good deals and in general do a better
job than the corrupt incompetent
lawmakers he said were wrecking the
country he was right they were wrecking
the country and yet today in remarkable
twist the president held the televised
meeting with the very swamp creatures he
once denounced he told them he trusted
them to craft immigration policy without
his input then he suggested he'd be
willing to accept any deal they produced
even a bad one
when this group comes back hopefully
with an agreement this group and others
from the Senate from the House comes
back with an agreement I'm signing it I
mean I will be signing it I'm not going
to say oh gee I want this or what that
helped you saw Megan because I have a
lot of confidence with something really
good at one point the president agreed
with Democratic Senator Dianne Feinstein
of California that it would be wise to
handle the question of daca separately
before negotiating any meaningful reform
of our broken and dysfunctional
immigration system I don't know how you
would feel about this but I'd like to
ask the question what about a clean daca
bill now and with the commitment that we
go into a comprehensive immigration
reform procedure like we get back on
remember when Kennedy was here it was
really a major major effort and it was a
great disappointment that no matter what
dick is saying we're going to come up
with daca we're gonna do daca and then
we can start immediately on the Phase
two which would be comprehensive key
allies very close to the President on
immigration told us this afternoon they
were shocked by what they saw in that
meeting it was a completely different
Donald Trump from the one we watched on
the campaign trail just two years ago
how different let's put it this way
Trump's rival from the 2016 race Jeb
Bush who was on the far left of
Republican sentiment on immigration
questions tweeted these words in
response the meeting quote encouraged
the president is seeking bipartisan
solutions to our immigration challenges
in 2016 Donald Trump ran on the premise
that America's borders ought to be real
that the repeated amnesties of the past
have betrayed voters and that this
country deserves an immigration policy
that looks out for American interests
rather than those of foreign countries
almost nobody in Washington agreed with
him at the time almost nobody in
Washington agrees with him now Congress
is full of people from both parties who
believe that the point of our
immigration policy is to provide cheap
labor to their donors and to atone for
America's imaginary sins against the
world they couldn't care less about
immigrations effect on you or your
family yet these are the same people the
president now says he trusts to write
the immigration bill the one he'll sign
no matter what it says so what was the
point of running for president you
remember the president also ran on his
skills as a negotiator and he clearly
has skills as a negotiator where were
they today the president signaled he'd
be happy to legalize hundreds of
thousands of illegal immigrants now and
then at some point in the future tackle
all that other stuff like making sure
they can't bring millions of their
relatives from the third world along
with them that's not much of a
negotiation anesthesia recipients is the
only leverage the White House has once
the president agrees to let them jump to
the head of the line ahead of millions
of other people hoping to come here
legally the negotiation is over at that
point
why would Democrats agree to anything
ending chain migration the diversity
lottery supporting a merit-based system
that might actually help a mare
no chance the Democrats goal is to
import more Democratic voters and by any
means necessary
once they retake the Congress and the
presidency and if Trump betrays his base
at immigration that'll definitely happen
it is over say goodbye to borders so
they are done keep in mind that the top
Democrat in the house recently thanked
illegal aliens for sneaking into this
country that's how Democrats feel and
they're not pretending anymore
being a trump voter isn't always easy
it's like rooting for the underdog in
baseball the old Chicago Cubs on one
level there is pride the pride that
comes from doing something that
fashionable people consider insane
that's a good feeling but there's also
some disappointment along the way and
honestly there's some embarrassment but
you silently bear it because you know
that when they finally win the World
Series it'll be worth everything you
went through every sarcastic dig from
your brother at law at Thanksgiving will
seem small by comparison in the Trump
presidency the World Series is this
immigration bill it's the big payoffs
the whole point of the exercise and
they're not allowed to blow it